récemment le maire de laval a déclaré
que parmi les grandes villes du québec
au cours des quatre dernières années
c'est sa ville qui avait la hausse de
taxe la plus ferme
l'augmentation du taux de taxation était
de 1 point
625 la plus faible parmi les cinq
guerres civiles
au québec on a vérifié et c'était pas
vrai
[Musique]
quand l'équipe du maire demers a su
composer une vérif sur sa déclaration
elle a tout de suite fait le calcul
et ils ont concédé qu avait une erreur
parmi les cinq plus grandes villes du
québec celle qui a eu la plus petite
augmentation c'est québec 4,74 % entre
2013 et 2017 suivi de laval 6 54%
montréal c'est dire que 5% longueuil
7,57 % et gatineau 12,11 % sur quinze
bon alors nous entre sont un peu
ennuyante de terminer notre vérifie si
on décide de comparer les dix plus
grandes villes du québec au point de vue
du fardeau fiscal pour une maison
unifamiliale l'endroit où ça coûte le
moins cher
c'est à saguenay suivi de lévis
sherbrooke longueuil et trois rivières
les plus élevées à l'endroit le plus
cher c'est à montréal suivi de père
bonne québec laval et gatineau en 2016
une maison unifamiliale moyenne à
saguenay avait un fardeau fiscal de 2
mille 525 dollars alors que montréal
même fardeau fiscal était de 3460 de
cette différence s'explique
essentiellement par deux raisons il y a
plus des services dans la région de
montréal comme par exemple le métro tous
les budgets qui vont à l'itinérance ou
encore le coût d'un méga services de
police comme le spvm est à saguenay la
valeur des maisons est moindre donc
difficile de récolter autant de taxes
qu'à montréal
si vous voulez qu'on vérifie autre chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]